so I'm gonna get super vulnerable with
you guys right now
um I think I'm gonna share with you a
lot of things that are maybe not so
flattering about me
um you know things or thoughts that
would be socially frowned upon so I was
just diagnosed with ADHD
now what
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to my channel a
reminder to hit my bio if you want to
get a free copy of my Hunger cushion
combo ebook and also to check out my ltk
page for today's fit today I'm going to
be getting super vulnerable and honest
and I'm gonna be telling you how I'm
feeling about my recent ADHD diagnosis
and also some next steps on this
self-discovery journey so a little bit
of a background here
um I've struggled with my mental health
for basically my whole life I had bad
anxiety since I was a kid I mean so my
earliest memories were basically of me
crying myself to sleep before a dance
competition because I was so afraid of
disappointing my coach and even my mom I
always won the trophies in the golds but
I was always so terrified that one day I
wouldn't and I was a really good kid
like at least that's what my mom said
she said that was perfect but you know I
wasn't a troubled kid I wasn't
disruptive I was was a people pleaser so
I just tried really really hard to be
good and honestly that never went away I
was always a top straight A student all
throughout high school and University I
actually graduated at the top of my
class with the top GPA in my program so
never ever ever did it cross my mind
that I had a learning disability like
ADHD like to me ADHD was just like
something for hyper little boys who were
disruptive in class and who needed extra
time on their exams because they were
slow I was definitely not that kid but
there's been a lot of talk about ADHD
since the start of the pandemic and a
lot of women are getting diagnosed in
their mid-30s who maybe historically
have been overlooked just because their
symptoms present completely differently
than young boys and this is partially to
do with less stigma more discussion like
I feel like our parents definitely did
not have as much therapy as we do today
but I think that there's now this whole
cohort of 30-something women who've
worked really really hard all their
lives to mask their symptoms and I feel
like when we were kids or even in our
20s we could do this because we had
virtually little to no responsibilities
but now we're adults and many of us are
moms many of us had our kids like during
the pandemic which was
traumaticus and basically all the coping
strategies that worked when things were
comparatively like easier or just not
working anymore so for myself I feel
like it's the combination of owning a
thriving business and having two kids
and a dog and a house all at the same
time it's just created such
like psychological chaos that I just had
to kind of relinquish my sense of
control which has basically been the
thing that has kept this perfect
neurotypical facade going for so long so
I used to be super over the top on the
ball like my motto in University was if
I'm not ahead I'm behind if you ain't
first you're last because basically the
thought of needing to catch up on like
anything so school work finances
anything was just so terrifying to me so
I would work like four weeks ahead in my
schoolwork just to like relieve that
anxiety
um also I would always hoard money for a
rainy day I still do I'm definitely a
money hoarder
and I mean even when I started working
in media trying to build my business in
my early 20s again when I didn't have
kids when I didn't have really any
responsibilities it was the same thing
right my agent would email me I would
reply immediately they would ask for a
piece of content I would create it that
day on the spot like no one ever had to
remind me anything nothing I was
reminding everybody else but in the past
five years I just like started dropping
so many balls and this has created so
much more anxiety for me because I have
felt so out of control and it's like
every single year it's just gone
progressively worse and my
overcompensation coping strategies are
just no longer working because there are
just too many variables to try to
control and it's feeling
completely overwhelming so I want to try
to describe to you what it feels like in
my brain every day at this point
at 35 so basically somebody emails me
and I see it but almost in like a dream
like State there but it's not quite
there it's not quite Computing and then
suddenly something else demands my
attention so it's my kid I gotta pee I
gotta get a snack I gotta clean up a
spill I gotta turn off the TV whatever
I'm replying to that email is Gonzo from
my head and then two hours goes by and
suddenly I'm like hit with this wave of
anxiety that's like oh my gosh I have to
respond to that email and my heart rate
spikes I feel like I can't catch my
breath I go to my mailbox and when I get
to my mailbox I see more emails that
distract me so that I forget again and
this is just one benign task out of
hundreds that I have to face in the day
so my day is basically just forgetting
remembering forgetting remembering up
down here there and I'm in this state
that is there but not quite there and
I'm also having all of these mini panic
attacks at all hours including through
the night remembering these things that
I have to do I also have remarkably
vivid dreams to the point that I often
tell people that I feel like I live a
whole other life at night and when I
wake up in the morning I remember
everything and I often don't know what's
real and what's not I work very hard in
the day and that I feel like I work very
hard at night and it is exhausting and
in the past I could manage all of this
because it was just me like all these
little demands in my life were all
pretty minor I was a student no one was
emailing me I didn't have a husband and
kids or a house or a dog I wasn't a
business owner or we're seeing a team of
12 people but now I kind of feel like
I'm in this galaxy of shooting stars
that are just like zooming past me
constantly and I don't know which way to
look and sometimes at the end of the day
I just cry out of exhaustion trying to
do it all and my husband is fairly
useful but no offense to men watching
women are just generally the bearer of
these burdens like even in more
egalitarian relationships but anyways I
ended up working with a psychologist I
did like five hours of tests and when I
received this diagnosis I actually
breathed a huge sigh of relief it has
been so validating to put all these
different pieces together all my
struggles throughout life things that I
felt embarrassed about that you know I
just couldn't grasp or cope with and I
finally have an explanation for it all
so I'm gonna get super vulnerable with
you guys right now
um I think I'm gonna share with you a
lot of things that are maybe not so
flattering about me
um you know things or thoughts that
would be socially frowned upon uh but
maybe if you recognize yourself in some
of these patterns it might Inspire even
just one person to reach out for help so
first of all as I mentioned it has been
incredibly validating to know that all
of the psychological diagnoses that I
have received in my life can potentially
be linked back to ADHD and that these
are not just some kind of like inherent
character flaws it's just how my brain
is wired so for one I have general
anxiety disorder I basically had this as
a childhood and I only started
medicating for this over a year ago and
I have to say that it's completely
changed my life and on my recent
evaluation with my doctor she actually
said that I no longer even fit the
diagnostic criteria for anxiety
basically thanks to medication and all
of the years of therapy that I've done
which is amazing but about 50 of people
with ADHD will also have anxiety
presenting together and one can
exacerbate the other and vice versa I
also was just diagnosed with something
called ocpd which is obsessive
compulsive personality disorder and it's
different from OCD because you know OCD
is often ruled by intrusive thoughts
that cause a lot of anxiety so a person
has to perform a lot of these
compulsions for Relief so you know
checking the door handle a bunch of
times checking if you unplug the
straightener a bunch of times or
performing any specific rituals in your
day I don't do that but ocpd is ruled by
perfectionism other common symptoms of
ocpd are things like supporting money
for worst case scenarios which I am
definitely known to do being over
devoted to work and productivity check
uh being very stubborn absolutely
stubbornness uh things like not wanting
to delegate tasks out of fear that they
won't be done perfectly
guilty and also this Obsession or desire
to have all these lists in order to
maintain order double check I love me a
good list I told you these are not
flattering parts of my personality I
actually get criticized a lot by you
know family members people I know for
these things and you would think that
ADHD which is characterized by like
impulsivity and then ocpd which is
characterized by perfectionism and order
like that these things could never
coincide but apparently they often do so
it's often believed that people with
ADHD May adopt ocpd behaviors as a way
to try to maintain some order in their
lives or like to try to sustain
functioning in academic or different
social scenarios which looking back is
absolutely what I've done in my life I
have overcompensated with extreme effort
extreme perfectionism because I did not
want to fail and disappoint others so in
a lot of ways you know I guess you could
say that my ocpd even though it's been a
huge struggle for me in my life has also
in some ways kind of Saved Me from some
of the downfalls of ADHD another
interesting comorbidity with ADHD is
eating disorders so this might apply to
a lot of you guys watching so research
has shown that girls with ADHD are four
times more likely to have an eating
disorder honestly every single time I
even think about these stats I feel some
relief like that it wasn't my fault that
I wasn't just vain or like easily
influenced by Media or the movies or
other things like that that I was
actually genetically programmed to have
these struggles but restrictive Eating
Disorders are often driven by a lot of
this kind of All or Nothing dichotomous
thinking which is also a common fixture
in folks with ADHD and in the case of
binge eating we also know that people
with ADHD have at least one defective
Gene that makes it difficult for our
neurons to respond to the pleasure
hormone dopamine so we tend to see
people with ADHD binch eat or have like
really strong desires for super sweet
Foods because they're constantly looking
for that big hit of dopamine that
they're lacking insomnia is another one
ADHD and insomnia are highly comorbid
especially early morning wake UPS which
is something that I have personally
always struggled with and this has to do
with the hyperactivity piece where my
brain and my body just like feel so
wired even though I know that I'm
completely run down and exhausted I
still just want to jump out of bed in
the morning there's also a really high
risk of addiction in folks with ADHD so
about half of people with untreated ADHD
will develop a substance abuse disorder
in their lives in some cases this is
related to the impulsivity tendencies in
some cases it's to like numb some of
those overwhelming or unpleasant
symptoms of ADHD and in other cases it
is to provide that jolt of dopamine that
us folks with ADHD are just so
Desperately Seeking now I have always
said that I have an addictive
personality which is why I resisted any
kind of sleep medications for so long
I've always just been worried it's a
slippery slope for me and I have to be
honest sometimes when I'm not feeling my
best psychologically I feel like I'm in
a battle of taking a bit too much then
having to painfully wean myself down
than taking too much then weaning myself
down it is like physically and mentally
draining for me to do this roller
coaster but I'm a rule follower because
I guess with the ocpd so I feel like if
I didn't have those Tendencies fighting
against the ADHD I might more easily
have ended up in a bad place you know
for less dangerous forms of addiction I
guess so like I definitely have a bit of
an addiction to online shopping but
again ocpd people pleasing personality
I'm worried about my husband getting mad
at me so that definitely rains me in a
little bit I also think one of the
reasons that I chose this job of working
in media specifically social media is
that I guess I crave the constant
dopamine hits that you get from every
little piece of content that goes out
like people are always saying social
media is creating these dopamine junkies
like we're constantly craving those
little hits all day long I know it's not
good for me but at least I Now
understand a little bit more about my
life choices hold that thought I'm gonna
pop these little frittatas in the oven
some other things that I know about
myself that I can now associate with
this diagnosis are things like my
forgetfulness I am
so forgetful if I remember something I
absolutely have to deal with it right
then and there or it will just like
float in my subconscious haunting me
without me fully being able to
acknowledge what it is it is really
debilitating I also fidget and move all
day long I have never been able to just
sit on the beach I can't lay in bed in
the morning I leap out of the bed in the
morning I can't even go for a massage
for more than 30 minutes because I am so
antsy and I move and I tap my fingers
constantly makes my husband crazy I am
always like playing music like a piano
with my fingers and the other
interesting thing is I always take my
business calls and my therapy walking on
the treadmill or walking outside and
this is even something that my therapist
in her evaluation noted down because I
find that when I'm taking calls sitting
down I just can't listen I I feel so
distracted with everything else in the
room around me I want to doodle I want
to check an email I want to see what the
dog's doing I I could hear every other
sound I can not concentrate whereas when
I'm walking and talking I can actually
just Zone in on what that person is
saying and apparently exercise is one of
the biggest recommendations for folks
with ADHD not only because it helps to
supply dopamine which again is kind of
naturally lower but it's also been shown
to help improve executive functioning it
improves impulsivity reduces aggression
improves memory lots more so I guess I
just instinctually knew that exercise
kind of gave me a rhythm to fall into so
that I could concentrate more on the
task at hand another less flattering
Abbey Quirk is that I'm a really really
bad listener you know that Meme on Tick
Tock if the cat just like zoning out I
laugh every single time I see one of
those videos because I can relate to
every every single one of them it
doesn't matter what the subject matter
is but I recently noticed this is an
issue because I started taking tennis
lessons as an adult and this is probably
the first time that I've had to be
taught anything as an adult because I'm
My Own Boss so normally people aren't
explaining to me what to do but with
tennis I cannot listen to my instructor
they're just so many distractions
they're involved there was kids in the
park there are kids playing there are
other people playing I'm like completely
overwhelmed so yeah it's not going as
well as I'd like it to but even though I
like think back to how I was in school
and even though I got really really good
grades I was never an auditory learner I
also am not one to stare at a screen or
a book all day that is also torture to
me but what I would do is I'd be very
hyper focused in class which is another
ADHD characteristic and I would copy
down what was said verbatim and then I'd
go home and I basically learn it by
memorization they actually have a
photographic memory and then once the
new stuff was memorized I would quickly
review everything else from the weeks
and lectures before that I'd memorized
and I think I did this because I would
never be able to sit long enough or
concentrate long enough to just cram for
an exam the night before like most of my
friends never and this was obviously my
silent ADHD but yeah the hyper focusing
that is not just with work or school my
husband always says I have tunnel vision
he always jokes that if I had a task or
something to do that I would just
steamroll an old granny and not even
notice just so I could get to the Finish
Line again not flattering but also a
super common ADHD trait so yes I am very
good at getting it done but ask my
husband I don't do anything except for
my work because I'm very passionate
about it I'm very thorough and I'm a
perfectionist but if I'm given a task
that I'm not so passionate about I will
botch it up it will be sloppiest like my
husband knows that he cannot give me a
household task because I will do it but
I will do it hastily to get it done
whereas he would spend months
researching options and prices to get
the best possible option I have zero
patience for that I just wanted that and
there are so many other challenges that
you know I have faced my life that I
know now are simply related to my brain
structure and function and chemistry
including that dysregulation of the
dopamine system when you learn about the
different comorbidities with ADHD
it is really scary like especially as a
mom knowing that ADHD is like 75 to 90
hereditary which means that if I have
ADHD there is a high chance that one or
both my kids will also but I also see
how I turned out and I'm very high
functioning and successful and resilient
despite all of the hardships that I have
had to face and I actually read Paris
Hilton's uh Memoir which was amazing by
the way in my opinion and she talks a
lot about having ADHD and how her ADHD
ended up being like a real superpower
for her clearly the girl's doing all
right so I too am just trying to see you
know the benefits in this but research
actually suggests that ADHD folks have a
lot of great traits problem solvers
demonstrate perseverance and resilience
they're great multitaskers they have
really strong morals and they tend to be
more empathetic and sensitive and
accepting and funny and entrepreneurial
and energetic and courageous and I feel
like I identify with all of these things
and I also feel like these traits have
been essential to my success in life and
there's also a ton of super successful
and smart neurospicy celebrities so John
Lennon Emma Watson Justin Timberlake
Ryan Gosling Michael Jordan Michael
Phelps Walt Disney Mozart Einstein
DaVinci Thomas Edison Alexander Graham
Bell like just to name a few these are
literally some of the most important
minds of all time so I'm choosing to see
being neurodivergent as this amazing
superpower like definitely one with
struggles but also one that will open up
new windows of opportunity because I am
able to see the world in this unique and
multi-layered way and I think my
frittatas are ready anyway I'm not
really sure what's next for me on this
journey I actually have not decided if
I'm going to medicate or when or how
much or with what like I'm still
meditating on that but for now I feel
like this has been a really validating
experience and as I said I'm choosing to
see this as a superpower and a blessing
but if you guys want more videos on ADHD
I would love to hear from you I am sure
I have a lot of neurospicy folks in my
community so please speak up and say
hello and on that note that's all that I
have for you guys today if you like it
give it a thumbs up and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]